ÇAber benimmst du dich anders
vor der TŸr als zu Hause?È
ÇDrastisch.È
ÇIch mšchte nicht
bei Philipp zu Hause sein.È
ÇIch bin zauberhaft.È
ÇLiebenswert.È
ÇIch bin in jedem Kontext
ein zauberhafter, liebenswerter Umgang.È
ÇSeitdem ich
dieses Buch gelesen habe,
hŸte ich mich wie die Pest davor,
dieses Wort zu benutzen.
AuthentizitŠt ist ein Begriff,
der ist so wahnsinnig positiv besetzt.È
ÇWahrheit, Echtheit.È
ÇAm Anfang dieses Buches
sagt er, wir mŸssen
zu einer ganz radikal anderen
Definition von AuthentizitŠt kommen.
AuthentizitŠt kann sich nur so definieren
als die Erwartung, die jemand hat,
stimmt Ÿberein mit dem,
was er wahrnimmt.È
ÇAlso du machst das so kompliziert!È
ÇWir nehmen ein Beispiel,
das Schilling auch nimmt.
Wenn du sagst, dass ist ein
authentisches, italienisches Restaurant.È
ÇGenau.È
ÇDann sagst du nichts Ÿber das Restaurant.È
ÇEntweder hat es Pizza,
dann sage ich, es ist authentisch,
weil ich mir vorstelle, jedes italienische
Restaurant muss eine Pizza servieren.
Oder es hat keine Pizza.
Dann sage ich, es ist Ümolto autenticoÝ,
weil in meiner Vorstellung
gerade das speziell italienisch ist.È
ÇGenau. Der Punkt ist, du sagst eigentlich
nichts Ÿber die Sache oder die Person,
die du als authentisch bezeichnest...È
ÇSondern nur Ÿber mich.È
Ç...Ÿber deine kulturellen Gepflogenheiten,
deinen Habitus, deine Erwartungen.
Mehr leistet dieser Begriff eigentlich nicht.
Was kšnnten wir vielleicht stattdessen
versuchen, zu entwickeln?È
ÇGenau. Das finde ich auch sehr schšn.È
ÇDas ist doch ein wundervoller Abschnitt,
wo er sagt: zum Beispiel ProfessionalitŠt.È
ÇDas nehme ich mit aus diesem Buch.È
ÇNicola lebt richtig auf.
ProfessionalitŠt in diesem Sinne,
wie Schilling das hier verwendet, heisst:
Es ist eben einfach professionell,
dass man in bestimmten Situationen
situations- und
kontextgebunden agiert.
Im Grunde betrifft es die Frage von Manieren.
Wenn du mir auf den Fuss trittst,
also versehentlich, fŸr den Fall,
dass du mich versehentlich trittst.
Und dann sagst: ÜEs tut mir wahnsinnig leidÝ.
Und ich sage, obwohl es wahnsinnig weh tut:
ÜDas macht nichtsÝ,
dann ist das nicht authentisch.È
ÇAuch das ÜEs tut mir leidÝ.È
ÇIch wŸrde sagen ÜBist du irreÝ
und du ÜEs tut mir Ÿberhaupt nicht leidÝ.
Aber der Umstand, dass wir uns nicht
authentisch benehmen in diesem Fall,
sorgt dafŸr, dass sowas wie Zusammenleben
oder Zivilisation Ÿberhaupt mšglich wird.È
ÇAlso Philipp ist fŸr mich
insofern authentisch...È
ÇTiefer Seufzer.È
ÇDu bist fŸr mich schon authentisch,
weil du zu dem stehst,
was du denkst und das
merkt man auch. Auch Widerwillen.
Du sagst einfach, was du denkst.È
Das klingt fŸr dich oft so.
Aber da kann ich dir versichern,
dass ich noch ungefŠhr 90% dessen,
was ich auch noch sagen kšnnte,
on top of that, nicht sage.
Wieso sprechen wir eigentlich die ganze Zeit
Ÿber mich in diesem Clip?È
ÇHabt ihr das kapiert?
Authentisch oder nicht authentisch.
Was findet denn ihr? Ist ÜauthentischÝ etwas Gutes,
oder etwas Schlechtes als Eigenschaft?È